[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[TUNING INSTRUMENTS]
JUDAH AKERS: How's
everybody doing?
Thanks so much for coming.
We love Detroit.
It's, like, one of those cities
that we like to try and travel
through, especially as of late.
We go to that coffee shop.
What's it called?
[LAUGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Starbucks?
JUDAH AKERS: Yeah, Starbucks.
We come to Google
to go to Starbucks.
[LAUGHTER]
But we've been here a few times.
We've played Royal Oak.
And then we played Magic Bag.
And then last
night, we played DTE
with Incubus and
Jimmy Eat World.
So Michigan has been an
early part of our story
from the very start.
One of our first ever house
shows outside of Nashville
was in Grand Rapids.
So it feels good to be back.
So thanks for having us, Google.
And this first song
is one of our--
I guess it came out
about five months ago.
And it's kind of written
out of this place
of this emotional roller
coaster of the year I
went through last year.
2016 was just kind of like super
high highs and super low lows
for me.
My first nephew was born.
And I just wasn't prepared
for the emotional reaction
I would have, just like
these bolts of joy.
And about a month
after that, my grandpa,
who I was very close with,
suddenly passed away.
And so it was just kind
of like a big bummer.
So it was just kind of like
this beautiful thing happened.
And then this really
sad thing happened.
And I don't know.
It's just like things like
that happen in a person's life.
And it makes you think
about, like, your life,
and like, what are you
doing with your life.
And what the heck would I even
tell this little human being
that came on the Earth
about life, because I
don't know what the heck.
You know?
And the general
synopsis that I got
is that you can control
certain things in your life,
and you don't have
control over other things.
And odds are you should
probably do something
about the things
you can control.
And with our music,
we really want
to implore people to go out
and live the life that you want
and be full of life because
this is the one that you got.
So this one's called
"Suit and Jacket."
[PLAYS GUITAR]
Also, I know 401(k)s are good.
We get tweets all the time.
It's like, oh, actually,
401(k)s are amazing.
I know.
It's not the purpose
of this song.
So when you hear that
line, don't judge me.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - "SUIT AND JACKET"
BY JUDAH & THE LION]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
Thank you.
That was so sweet.
Thank you so much.
BRIAN MACDONALD: That was louder
than the crowd last night.
[LAUGHTER]
JUDAH AKERS: We
were telling Jason,
we got to do a couple of
tours over in Scandinavia.
And after the first show, like--
I don't know.
We're from Nashville and
maybe a lot like people
in Detroit, people in
the South, especially.
And last night was pretty great.
It was amazing too.
It's like our Detroit shows
have shown this as well.
But people in the
South just, like,
are crazy at a lot of shows,
especially when there's
a banjo.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, that was a
redneck joke, but--
It's just that we like to
have fun at our live shows.
And our first show in Sweden was
at this small cafe-pub thing.
And we were surprised.
It was after our first record.
400 people showed up in this
very small town in Sweden.
And we were like, this
is going to be awesome.
And after our set, we got
back in the green room area.
And we were like, we suck.
Like, nobody-- we're not like
translating internationally,
blah, blah.
We're like, we need to quit.
And then we all of a sudden
start hearing clapping like--
[SLOW CLAPPING]
And all of the 400
people in this small cafe
were like clapping in unison.
And that's how they called
for an encore in Sweden.
And we finished the
song, go back out.
They call for another encore.
It's like, we're a young band.
We don't know too many
songs past our set list.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, we found out that
in Sweden, people were just
like shy or more bashful.
They way they come to shows is
just they're going to listen.
They're going to clap.
They're not going to be
standing up and jumping around
or whatever.
So I don't know where I
was going with that story.
All I'm saying is
that you were louder
than that crowd in Sweden.
That makes us feel a
lot better, more secure
with what we're doing up here.
So I appreciate that.
But after that tour-- we
did a tour in the winter.
And if you know
Sweden, in the winter,
it's like the sun comes out,
like, one hour of the day
if you're lucky.
And it was just like
this beautiful--
like, we did like 28 shows
in 30 days or something
in the winter.
And it was just kind of this
beautiful, overwhelming tour.
And then we went
back in the summer.
And it's the complete
opposite in the summer.
The sun sets at midnight,
comes right back up.
People are, like,
walking their babies
by the river at 11
o'clock, sipping on a beer.
It's like, you have to
go to sleep sometime.
So it's just like this very,
very polar opposite country.
It feels like a
different country
when we went there
in the summer.
So we kind of fell in love
with Sweden, in particular,
Stockholm.
And we wrote a song about
Stockholm in the summer.
That's this song.
[MUSIC - "STOCKHOLM"
BY JUDAH & THE LION]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
Thank you.
BRIAN MACDONALD: Thanks, y'all.
So we wanted to play
a cover song for you.
A little bit about us, so
these are traditional bluegrass
instruments.
I don't know if you guys know.
I'm from Chicago.
I didn't know what a mandolin
was until I moved to Nashville.
But yeah, me and Nate, we all
met in college in Nashville.
And me and Nate had just kind
of picked out these instruments
and started messing around.
And that was around the
time that we met Judah.
So I guess bluegrass has a
big influence on our sound
because we play
these instruments.
But in reality, our influences
are pretty widespread.
And when we were
growing up, we listened
to all kinds of hip-hop,
and rock, and all that.
So that's more how we play.
But this is traditional
bluegrass song
that we like to do.
It's called "Little Girl
of Mine in Tennessee."
[PLAYS MANDOLIN]
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
BRIAN MACDONALD: Yeah, if y'all
want to stand up and square
dance and whatever--
[LAUGHTER]
JUDAH AKERS: We do
have a bluegrass dance.
I'll do it for this song.
It's gonna be a
little awkward, but--
So we do this thing at
or show where Nate--
it looks better on
Nate,because he's got the beard
and the banjo.
You just gotta have to get
into athletic position,
like you're playing
defense in basketball, just
with the duck feet.
You bend down like this.
And then you move
you feet like that.
[LAUGHTER]
That's the bluegrass position.
It's acts as a really
good leg workout too.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Ready?
Let's do it.
BRIAN MACDONALD: Are you good?
JUDAH AKERS: [INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC - "LITTLE GIRL OF MINE IN
TENNESSEE"]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
I even broke a strong.
That's the one rule
for bluegrass, so--
out of tun and break a string.
Yep.
It's the first banjo joke here.
Some people call
it the chainsaw.
But you can turn a chainsaw off.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPENCER CROSS: We
have an official--
I don't know what
I'm talking about.
But we have an official banjo
talk that Brian always tells.
And Nate started
with the punchline.
[LAUGHTER]
It's what's the difference
between a chainsaw and a banjo?
A chainsaw has an
on and off switch.
[WEAK LAUGHTER]
BRIAN MACDONALD: That was good.
JUDAH AKERS: Thank you, man.
BRIAN MACDONALD: They don't
get the banjo jokes up here,
up in the North.
JUDAH AKERS: Well, thanks
a lot for having us.
It really does mean a lot.
We're gonna be back in the area.
I guess Grand Rapids is not
really the area here, is it?
But i think we
have plans to keep
coming back here to Detroit.
We told our agent that
we want this place
to be one of our places
we call home on the road.
So thanks so much
for having us again.
And this last song is our single
called "Take it all Back."
And we kind of wrote this
song out of a this place
of redefining what
success means to us.
After our very first record,
we had the opportunity
to play on the David
Letterman show.
And it was right
before he retired.
And we never even
saw it in our stars.
Because we were coming
out with a record.
He had already announced
he was retiring in May.
The record was coming
out in February.
So we were just like, dang it.
We missed that one, blah, blah.
He ended up really liking
the record or whatever.
And we ended up getting to
play in March-ish or something
like that.
I don't know.
It was just like
this moment for us
as young band,
especially, of like,
we did something
cool, and especially
to be on stage with Dave.
And you kind of watch
legends as a kid growing up.
And he's like a
legend of himself.
He's kind of the
guy, for me at least,
that was always on
at night or whatever.
And it's just kind of
funny how moments like that
can happen in your life.
And maybe you can relate
to this with whatever you
do as well, whether it's
business or whatever.
Moments like that can
be such a positive thing
and have just great
influence on you,
but can also blur
your intentions.
For us, musically,
like I said earlier,
we just want to make music
that's life-giving to people
and hopefully can
help people out
because that's the way
music has been for us
and the way we like
to receive music.
When moments like that
happen, and success
can become more about
Instagram followers
and selling more tickets
and know x and y,
playing more late night
TV shows or whatever.
And those things have
its place for what we do.
I mean, of course, we
have to pay our bills.
But if that's what
success is, then
we're never going
to reach success,
because it doesn't matter if
you're Bono or Taylor Swift,
you can always
sell more tickets,
and you can always have
more Instagram followers.
Taylor Swift's doing OK
on Instagram followers.
[LAUGHTER]
But this song is just
in a simple nature,
like no matter how many
people are singing, the banjo,
or whatever, we're
waking up to the fact
that success is about us making
a lot of good music for people.
So thanks so much for coming.
I hope everybody has an
amazing week, an amazing day.
I can't wait to be back.
This is called
"Take it all Back."
[MUSIC - "TAKE IT ALL
BACK" BY JUDAH & THE LION]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thanks again
to Judah & the Lion
for playing a couple
of songs for us.
That was awesome.
Let's give them one
more round of applause.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
And thank you, guys.
You guys were in Detroit, DTE.
You guys are heading
to Cleveland tomorrow,
which is close to
my hometown, as we
were talking about earlier.
Thanks for spending
your day off with us.
We really appreciate it.
Other than drinking
coffee at Starbucks
and hanging out with
tech nerds at Google,
what do you guys
typically do on a day off?
If you weren't coming
here, what would you guys
be doing this afternoon?
JUDAH AKERS: We're
pretty sporty.
I don't know if you guys
play Spikeball or KanJam,
or throw the frisbee.
We try to stay active.
Or go on a run, score
coffee in the city, write.
BRIAN MACDONALD: Golf.
JUDAH AKERS: Golf.
SPEAKER: Michigan's
great for golf.
So if you ever need
recommendations next time
you come through
town, especially over
in Grand Rapids, there's some
good courses, so let us know.
JUDAH AKERS: For sure.
SPEAKER: Cool.
We ask hard-hitting
questions here at Google,
as you saw from
that first question.
This next one--
SPENCER CROSS: I ask
Google [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Thanks, Spencer,
for the reciprocation.
We appreciate it.
SPENCER CROSS: This ad is
brought to you by Google.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Thank you.
SPENCER CROSS: Oh, and it talks.
SPEAKER: Nate, this question
is being directed to you guys,
or to you.
Excuse me.
True or false, the banjo
is the sexiest instrument
in a rock band.
NATE ZUERCHER: I'm the only
single one in the band.
So I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: False.
NATE ZUERCHER: Am I
keeping people away or--
SPEAKER: Nate, I've
read a couple articles
where you classify Judah &
the Lion's sound as booty pop
and banjo music.
I think we got a sense of that.
Was it hard for you guys?
You guys are known for your
energetic shows, right?
So I've seen you
guys live before.
You guys like to move
around a lot on stage.
Was it hard for you guys, for
the most part, to sit on stools
and play quietly for the most
part for us here at Google?
Do you guys want to
jump around with us?
We could have done that.
BRIAN MACDONALD: Yeah.
Well, being so early
in the morning,
I think it kind of
balanced it out.
But you saw in the third
song, like, a couple of us
wanted to stand up and
tap the toes a little bit.
SPEAKER: Could you guys talk--
I'm sure you've told
this story many times.
But I think it's
really interesting
because you guys all come
from very distinct backgrounds
and different places
around the country.
But you all bring
similar musical tastes
that have led to what you
guys sound like today.
Do you guys mind
recapping for us
here where you guys each
came from, how you guys met,
and then how you guys formed
the progression of the sound
that you guys have today?
BRIAN MACDONALD: Yes, for sure.
SPEAKER: That's a
three-part question.
So if you guys can remember
all those, that's bonus points.
Sorry about that.
BRIAN MACDONALD: So
I grew up in Chicago.
I started learning on piano
when I was, like, nine,
and kind of evolved from there.
I picked up guitar.
And right before
I went to college,
which is where we
met at Belmont,
I started playing mandolin.
So that's kind of my story.
JUDAH AKERS: Yeah, Spencer
grew up playing jazz drums
and played in marching
band and grew up
on bands like Boston and--
who were some other influences?
Chicago, all the cities.
And then Nate,
both of his parents
were in the Colorado Symphony.
And his dad grew up
teaching the trumpet.
And his mom is, like, this
virtuoso piano player,
who taught Nate to play
trumpet first and then piano.
But Nate was like this metal,
punk rock kid growing up
and somehow ended
up with a banjo.
And then I grew up
like super jockey.
I loved basketball and AU.
And in my dad's car, it would be
like, Eminem, 50 Cent, Run DMC,
A Tribe Called Quest,
that type stuff.
And then my mom's car was more
like Tom Petty, REO Speedwagon,
REM, Queen, those
type of sounds.
So it's just kind of funny.
And Miles Davis had
this quote, going
into your next question
about how we got together
and how our sound formed.
He said, it could
take you a lifetime
to figure out how you sound.
That's not word-for-word, but
that's the general idea of it.
It's like I think
we discovered--
because we met in
college, kind of randomly,
at a school called Belmont
University in Nashville.
And it was my junior year.
I was playing
baseball and starting
to take writing more seriously
just because I'd always
do it like since a young kid,
but never really recorded
anything.
I had this idea to record this
EP just so my mom would shut up
about it, just so she would
be satisfied with her EP
that I was going to make her.
And then I asked--
Nate was a friend
of my roommate's.
Nate and Brian were friends.
And then Brian and
Spencer were friends.
And so it all just
randomly came together.
And that first time
we met, I remember
calling my mom, just
maybe heavy, or not heavy,
but emotional.
I just remember I called
my mom crying, just
like, I think I've found
the song of the South
that I really like.
Because I come
from this really--
I didn't know I was a redneck
until I moved to Nashville.
It's like one of those moments.
So I grew up in this town
where banjo and mandolin were
very familiar
instruments for me,
but I'd never written
music for them.
So it was almost
like I was going back
to my roots a little
bit with the sound.
And just over the
course of time,
we spent so much time in
the van traveling and trying
to cultivate our live show
and talking about new records
and just thinking about
that Miles Davis quote
of just trying to figure
out what Judah & the Lion
sounds like.
Over the course of
time, when Nate's
doing the auxiliary
chord, DJing in the van,
playing EDM and Naked and
Famous, and Manchester
Orchestra.
And Brian's got it.
He's playing Billy Joel.
And Spencer's playing
Florida Georgia Line
and Boston, Chicago.
We run the gamut of influences .
And we really
wanted to make music
that wasn't limited by that.
Because this day and age, Google
knows just as good as anybody,
with the world we
live in, people
have access to all
different types of music.
And most everybody that at
least are maybe fans of us
like all music genres.
There might be one
or two that you hate.
But that's kind of like
the general synopsis.
So we wanted to make music
that we all liked and enjoyed
but that was unique to us.
So that was a bit
of a long answer.
SPEAKER: That was perfect.
JUDAH AKERS: But it
hits all the points.
SPEAKER: And you mentioned
some of this being cultivated
in the long van trips.
You guys did something like
200-some shows or 150--some
shows in 2015.
And that continues.
You guys are touring a ton.
Can you talk a little bit
about this current tour?
And what are the
differences between where
you guys are at now--
I heard that you guys have
upgraded the van to a bus now.
So that's a big
step for any band.
So how it started, you guys
were touring around in the van
doing a ton of shows a year.
You guys are now playing DTE,
which is absolutely massive.
What's that been
like for you guys
making that progression from
the grassroots touring, DJing
your own van to now being on
these big tour buses touring
around with some huge bands?
BRIAN MACDONALD: Yeah, mad
respect to Cletus, our van.
It's a white Ford, 15
passenger, parked in Nashville
in a parking lot.
SPENCER CROSS:
That sounds so sad.
[LAUGHTER]
It's pining away.
BRIAN MACDONALD: No,
it still takes us
to the airport
from time to time.
SPENCER CROSS: But she's
an old van, probably
like 10,000 miles [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN MACDONALD: Yeah.
No, it's been super
cool being in a bus.
I think it just helps
our morale, being
able to get eight hours
of sleep and spread out,
have personal space.
There's more time in
the day, because we're
driving at night and sleeping.
And it's just one less thing
to have to think about.
But yeah, I think it's been--
I don't know.
I don't know if I have anything
more to say about that.
Cletus lives.
SPEAKER: I've always
wanted to be on a tour bus.
But it sounds like Cletus
did a pretty good job too
for you guys.
So that's awesome.
Can you guys talk a little bit
about your newish album, so
"Folk Hop N' Roll."
I read a quote from you, Judah.
And I think I heard too
that this album was written
or produced in about two weeks.
That was a very
quick turnaround.
And I also read this
quotation from you, Judah,
that a lot of the
songs were written
with your live show
in mind, that you
wanted to put a lot of
energy into these songs,
and you wanted them to
resonate in your live shows.
Can you talk about, I
guess, just the process
of putting together
a record so quickly,
and then also letting some of
your musical influences shine
through and some of
that stage presence
as well in the songs
that you guys wrote?
SPENCER CROSS: I
was gonna say, yeah,
I think as far as
the quickness, there
are a couple of factors at play.
One was that we didn't have that
much money to record longer.
And also, our producer
at the time, Dave Cobb,
together, we had
this mindset of just
like going in and capturing
that kind of natural sound
just like right off the bat.
He's really big on just
capturing what feels right,
rather than slaving
away to get it perfect
and get the perfect take.
It's more about just
getting that-- maybe it's
the first take
that sounds great.
Maybe you didn't
play it perfect,
but that's what's
going on the record.
So it takes less time.
But it's kind of
freeing in a way.
But yeah, with that album,
speaking of the band,
after the first
album, there were
a lot of songs written with
these new relationships
with the mandolin
and banjo in mind.
But as we spent more
time together in the van
and got to know
our musical tastes
and our different
inspirations, we really
wanted those to shine through,
because that's who we are.
And we didn't want
to be limited by,
oh, we should sound like this
because we have a mandolin
or banjo in our band.
Like, we should play this
kind of music, when we really
love hip-hop, and
we really love rock.
And Nate loves EDM.
And so we wanted to have all
these different influences
speak through.
And so when we
approached the album,
we tried to flip
it around and not
be inhibited by any kind of box.
So that was the
inspiration for doing it,
just speaking honestly and
musically and lyrically
and seeing what happens.
JUDAH AKERS: Yeah, and I
think to piggy-back off that,
we've always been an indie band.
And radio, we never
really thought radio
would be a part of our story.
It just kind of happened
in the last six months.
And so when we wrote records,
it was for the live show
because that was what we were
doing to grow and to maintain
the ship.
And our live show is
really important to us.
We always like going to
shows concerts that we go to.
We want to see like--
we want to be entertained.
I want to go to a
show and not be bored.
And if somebody
is up there, just
playing the song or whatever,
not interacting with the crowd,
it doesn't really
connect with me.
And so even some of the lyrics
or whatever in the song,
they're kind of
simplistic in nature,
just to ring true
in a live show,
because that's especially
what we were doing at the time
to grow.
SPEAKER: Another question,
just since we're at Google,
we always try to
ask one somewhat
technology-based question.
Nothing too hard.
Don't worry about it.
We talk a lot about the
culmination of the music mixing
with technology, things
like social media,
things like selling your
music online, streaming music.
Where do you guys stand in
this whole kind of scenario
where it comes to
either fan interaction,
posting videos on YouTube,
streaming on things
like Spotify or Pandora?
Do you guys see that as
being a huge benefit to you
as a band that's come
up in the digital age?
Or do you wish there was less
of that, more vinyl, more
cassettes, things like that, to
make things a little bit more
physical, more easy on you guys?
NATE ZUERCHER: I think--
we get asked similar
questions to that often.
In the age that we grew up,
downloading and streaming
became popular when we
were in elementary school.
And so it's what we've
known, I guess, in some ways.
And so we hear all the time
that people are-- essentially
from record label folks,
they're making less money
when people are streaming.
But we're just excited
that people have
access to what we're doing.
But with our
career, we've always
known the way we make
money is from live shows.
And so we're not really
that point at all
where we can get upset that--
I'm almost like, here,
just take our music,
like, just spread it around.
And when we got started
too, we gave everything away
on noise [INAUDIBLE].
I don't know if you--
basically, you
give your EP away,
and they give you
email in return.
And it's free.
And they can tip if they want.
But it's just a way to--
I think we got 40,000
emails off our first EP.
And that was how
we toured it first
was sending out
notifications to those people
and letting them
know we were around.
But yeah, I mean,
it's cool to have--
I have hundreds of CDs
at home of all the bands
that I loved growing up.
So in that way, it's
cool to appreciate
and have a physical thing.
But I think we're just glad
that people can listen to us.
And it makes it easy to share.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah, my
friends make fun of me
because I still have a pile of
CDs sitting in the passenger
seat of my car.
They think I'm some
old-school guy.
But I like being
able to hold on--
JUDAH AKERS: You'll be the
hipster in, like, five years.
SPEAKER: Exactly.
I'm already working
on it, right?
SPENCER CROSS: You have to
wait until CDs are cool again.
SPEAKER: I'll start
wearing flannel shirts.
It'll be perfect.
So you mentioned touring
is huge for you guys.
We already touched on the fact
of your history of touring.
We talked a little bit earlier.
You guys are wrapping
up your summer tour
here towards the end of August.
And then you're going
off on another round
through the States.
And then you're
heading over to Europe
for a lot of dates
across the continent.
What do you guys hope
to get out of that?
We talked about connection with
fans and growing your fan base
and spreading your music.
What's your ultimate
goal for a big tour
like that for you guys?
JUDAH AKERS: I think
we've always dreamed
of being an international band.
And it worked out go to Sweden
and Scandinavia the first time
because this label over
there just had a grant,
I think, even from the
government to bring us over.
And so we didn't lose
money on that tour.
But I think what's difficult
for a young band getting over
to Europe is it's
really expensive.
And so we're just hoping to kind
of like establish a foundation,
like a little bit what we
did here in America with just
like grassroots.
We're going over there.
We're opening up for
band called Kaleo.
They're an Icelandic band.
They're a really,
really cool band.
And we did a couple
of shows with them
here in Canada as well.
And so I don't know.
We're just hoping to get
over there and experience
different cultures,
new people, hopefully
bring our music into
that place so it
can be a place where we
can continue go back to
and connect with.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
Well, listen,
guys, we appreciate
you coming in to Google
Detroit, to Google in general.
The music was fantastic.
We wish you guys
the best of luck.
It seems like there's huge
things coming for you guys.
And we're really
excited to be a part
of that journey for you guys.
Thank you guys once
again for coming in.
We appreciate it.
JUDAH AKERS: Yeah, thank you.
BRIAN MACDONALD:
Thanks for having us.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]